Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
authentication in Burp Scanner. So there are three sections in the settings where you can configure
different authentication related settings. So I'm going to go through each one now,
what you can configure and what it does. So let's just jump straight into Burp and have a look.
If I open up a new scan, first off here we have the application login settings. So here you can
configure two types of logins. First off is using login credentials, a username and a password.
So if you set these up, if Burp crawler encounters a simple login form, so just a username and password,
it can use these configured credentials to fill that in and log in nice and easy.
Secondly, we have recorded login sequences. So rather than trying to add support for every single
different type of login out there, and this gets really difficult especially when things like SSO
providers are introduced and just there's a thousand and one different ways of doing a login.
So rather than trying to add support for every single one, always playing catch up, we introduce
recorded login sequences. So these are JSON definitions that drive a browser and tell it exactly what to do
and how to log in. I'll probably go into a little bit more detail on recorded logins in an upcoming video,
just save it a little bit of time here. So next up, let's hop into the scan configuration, create a new custom crawling configuration.
So the first thing I wanted to go over is this crawl using my provided logins only in the crawl optimization here.
So normally, Burp crawler will do a multi-phase approach to crawling. It'll do several passes.
So if you've set up login credentials or recorded logins, it will first try to crawl as much of the application as possible
without using your login. So if it encounters any login forms, it just won't use them and it won't use
your recorded logins just yet. So this is trying to find as much unauthenticated content as possible.
However, if you select this option, we won't do that. We will just use your provided logins. So in the case of
plain credentials, we will crawl unauthenticated until we spot a login form and then we will immediately stop.
Move on to crawling with an authenticated context using your credentials and using that form we've
identified. If you've given us a recorded login, we don't even have to do that. We can just start
crawling with your recorded logins immediately. So this is a really useful setting for if you know
that your application has very little to no unauthenticated areas or in particular, if you have,
let's say again, an SSO and when you hit any of your start URLs, you immediately get redirected to
a login process. In this case, there's really no point doing an unauthenticated pass and you may as
well just crawl only using the provided logins. Finally, we've got this login function setting.
It's a grayed out because I've got that one selected. So these control what Burp Crawler should
automatically do when it encounters a login form. Again, this is just a simple username, password,
login form.
So first off, we have attempt to self-register a user. If this is set up, Burp Crawler will identify
what it thinks might be a registration form in addition to a login form. This is usually something
with a username and a password and then many other fields. What we'll then do is use this form to try
and register a user and then in the same way as if you provided the credentials yourself, it will do a
follow-up pass using its self-registered credentials and try to find as much authenticated content with
those credentials as possible. Secondly, we've got trigger login failures. So this is just what Burp
Crawler should do if it finds a login form when it's trying to crawl unauthenticated. With this setting on,
it will try to submit those forms just using bogus credentials. So just a randomly generated username
and password. And this is trying to, as it says, trigger login failures. If you turn this off, then
if we see a login form while crawling, we'll just completely ignore it knowing that we'll either come
back to it if you've given us credentials or just if you haven't completely ignore it altogether.
So that's all of the ways you can configure authentication for a Crawler audit. I haven't
covered platform authentication here because that's more of a desktop-wide network
stack setting. So perhaps one of the desktop team can go over that in future.